en el vídeo pasado mostramos
de hecho probamos que la derivada con
respecto a x de seno inverso de x es
igual a 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 1 -
x cuadrada te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo y trates de hacer el
mismo tipo de prueba para encontrar la
derivada con respecto a x del coseno
inverso de x entonces qué es lo que
queremos encontrar aquí queremos
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
del coseno inverso de x supongo que ya
lo intentaste y ahora hagámoslo juntos
siguiendo el mismo procedimiento que el
vídeo anterior
supongamos entonces que ya es igual a
coseno inverso de x lo cual quiere decir
que x x es igual a coseno de y ahora
vamos a derivar con respecto a x ambos
lados para obtener del lado izquierdo la
derivada de x con respecto a x es igual
a 1 y del lado derecho aplicamos la
regla de la cadena la derivada de coseno
de jake con respecto a iu
- seno del x la derivada de g
con respecto a x de jane de x vamos a
despejar de jane de x dividiendo ambos
lados entre menos seno de ley para
obtener que deje en de x es igual a
menos 1 sobre seno de iu y al igual que
en el vídeo anterior aquí tenemos la
derivada en términos de i y la
necesitamos en términos de x como
sabemos que x es igual a coseno de y
veamos si podemos escribir este
denominador en términos de coste no de y
en vez de seno de y para esto podemos
usar al igual que hicimos en el vídeo
anterior la identidad pitagórica es
decir seno cuadrado de i + coseno cuado
de iu es igual a 1 a partir de ahí
podemos obtener que seno de iu es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de uno menos coseno
cuadrado de ella así es que esto es
igual a menos 1 sobre la raíz y a partir
de la identidad pitagórica obtenemos que
la raíz de 1 - coseno cuadrado del hilo
así pero lo voy a escribir mejor de esta
manera para que quede más claro lo que
voy a hacer y que es coseno de yale ya
sabemos que coseno de 10x así es que
esto es igual a menos 1 sobre la raíz
cuadrada de uno menos coseno del xx esto
de aquí que ya vimos que es x coseno de
y lo voy a poner mejor con otro color
1 - x elevada al cuadrado y ya lo
tenemos la derivada con respecto a x de
coseno inverso de x es igual a déjame
ponerlo con otro color voy a ponerlo con
magenta esto es igual a menos 1 sobre la
raíz de uno menos x cuadrada y este es
un resultado bastante interesante un
resultado muy interesante y también
podemos compararla con la derivada de
seno inverso de x
de hecho la voy a poner una junto a la
otra para que veas para que puedas
apreciar que la única diferencia es el
signo entonces
copio y
pero voy a ponerle aquí aquí al lado
para que queden una al lado de la otra
ahí está aquí tenemos la diferencia la
derivada con respecto a x de coseno
inverso de x es menos 1 sobre la raíz de
uno menos x cuadrada mientras que la
derivada con respecto a x de seno
inverso de x es la misma expresión solo
que positiva